it's the 20th anniversary of american
idol and i realize that's how we met
eric the actor the first time he called
in he wanted a date with kelly clarkson
that was the first season eric how old
are you
27. what's wrong with you there's
something wrong right well i'm a
disabled person i'm
uh only three foot five three foot six
we got to get you down here you're in
love with kelly clarkson of american
idol yep maybe we can hook you two uh
kids up if i can get her to come in here
maybe i can hook you up with her well
what am i not for sure you got pictures
ever hanging on your wall
no but on my computer i have some photos
when you're whacking it do you think
about kelly clarkson no tell the truth
no all right thanks
eric the actor died of heart problems on
september 20th 2014
we never introduced eric the actor to
kelly clarkson we couldn't make that
happen which i really did try we tried a
couple of times but at least we had high
pitch call him and pretend to be kelly
clarkson
hello
hello
this is callie clarkson this is not
kelly clarkson this is
more than likely high pitch isn't it now
who's high pitch this is kelly clarkson
i think you're very cute
i pitch
give it up
i know it's you
a moment like this
some people wait a lifetime
wow
hi pitchmaster have any trouble
distinguishing voices
no he knew he know
and then i remember eric's fascination
with kelly clarkson kind of died off and
then he got into diana de garma who was
another contestant yeah really into her
and then uh we pulled off a miracle we
got diana degarmo to come in the studio
meet with eric
how do you feel what do you want to say
to your your idol good to see you again
good to see you too han
eric you're standing there in in shock
right next to her uh do you want i
eric's a little shy i think he'd say to
you diana
i've loved you from afar i fell in love
with you on american idol look at his
face and if eric if i'm saying something
wrong i'm gonna you stop me
and i think what eric wants maybe going
a little over no he's not am i eric you
know it definitely was cool getting to
meet you the two different times that we
met in california and
you know hopefully
we can continue to
see each other meet me with each other
yeah definitely at the shows and stuff
like that
love that kid and then the whole thing
with sanjaya there was a guy on american
idol i forget what season it was
but
the the general rap on him was that he
wasn't a good singer but
you know whatever but we got this whole
movement going just to [ __ ] with uh
eric the actor we were like backing the
idea that you should vote for sanjaya
even if he isn't the best and eric
pleaded with me
to stop this movement because he said it
would ruin american idol
i was going to
tonight i was
on and
you guys have a whole bunch of whiskers
i thought maybe to get this week to be
sanjaya's last week
eric i'm thinking of something else how
great would it be this season on
american idol because there's nobody
really that good
if everyone banned together and voted
for sanjaya that would probably be funny
but that would totally completely ruin
that tour who are you excited about
becoming the next american idol
which which one
really actually no one
just not him
yeah
so i thought well let's get let's vote
for sanjaya that whole sanjaya movement
i'm ben this is this is a good moment in
american idol history benji saw a
broadcast going on it was cnbc he saw it
happening on the street and he broke
into the broadcast to say vote for
sanjaya
askme which represents about 800 million
dollars in pension funds submitted this
proposal
is this about no it isn't vote sanjaya
show america that we can vote
no it is important no i am an american i
will vote for sanjaya
obviously having a few issues for poor
mary who's outside of carnegie hall
yeah talk about issues
sanjina i think
he did straighten it out but sanjina is
kind of funny
it is kind of funny and benji spent
three years in prison for doing that
which is not funny